herr lindner wenn sie das hören glauben
sie dass am ersten dezember wieder
geöffnet wird oder kommt der dritte
lockte das kann jetzt niemand seriös
sagen aber wir müssen jetzt sprechen
über die möglichen alternativen um es
mal klar zu sagen
frau klöckner erzählt die unwahrheit in
rheinland-pfalz wenn es nach der fdp
ginge bliebe die gastronomie offen
und dafür hat auch unser
stellvertretender ministerpräsident dort
geworben wir haben nur eben keine
absolute mehrheit sondern arbeiten in
koalition und ich lasse mich hier gerne
vorwerfen dass wir uns nicht durchsetzen
können aber dennoch sagen was eigentlich
notwendig wäre und im zweiten punkt von
frau klöckner auf sie sagt ja es gebe ja
keine alternative oder man würde keine
alternative benennen ich gebe den
vorwurf zurück es gibt gegenwärtig keine
offene klare diskussion über die
alternativen im gegenteil es wird der
eindruck erweckt die jetzige
krisenstrategie hätte keine alternative
und das überzeugt mich nicht
es gibt eine reihe auch von namhaften
persönlichkeiten die andere vorschläge
unterbreitet haben
es läuft darauf hinaus dass insbesondere
die menschen bei denen ein schwerer
krankheitsverlauf zu befürchten ist und
die dann auch die intensivbetten belegen
würden dass wir die in besonderer weise
schützen
das sind ältere menschen die in
pflegeeinrichtungen sind bis hin zu
menschen die jetzt zu hause leben wo wir
nachbarschaftshilfe organisieren können
und das wäre die eigentliche nationale
kraftanstrengung die nationale
kraftanstrengung liegt nicht darin alles
zu zumachen und dann schulden
aufzunehmen das irgendwie zu
kompensieren die nationale
kraftanstrengung wäre die besonders
schutzbedürftigen die besonders
gefährdeten in ganz besonderer weise ins
zentrum zu stellen
darüber hinaus dafür zu sorgen dass wir
in unserem land regionale geht man falls
harte maßnahmen ergreifen inklusive auch
der schließung etwa von solchen
illegalen partys da würde ich übrigens
auch die gäste mit in anspruch nehmen
und auch denen ein bußgeld und ich mit
dem veranstalter zumuten und diejenigen
die darüber hinaus sagen ich halte es
für verantwortbar als mensch ohne
vorerkrankung am öffentlichen leben
teilzunehmen aber wir sollen das kann
deshalb meine frage wenn wir mit der
strategie weitermachen wie wir sie jetzt
erleben
aus ihrer sicht müssen wir dann mit
einem dritten vierten fünften rechnen
aber selbstverständlich müssen wir das
weil das virus wird nach dasein ein
impfstoff wird es nicht geben jetzt
brechen wir eine welle dann kommen die
menschen weihnachten und über neujahr
zusammen
hier kann man doch daran fühlen wenn sie
einen grundlegend etwas verändert hat
das dann selbstverständlich wieder
fallzahlen steigen können dann sind wir
in derselben situation wie jetzt
wenigstens wenigstens sollte den
november jetzt genutzt werden dass wir
meinetwegen auch parteiübergreifend
einmal darüber sprechen was können wir
tun um das land wieder zu öffnen um
öffentliches kulturelles
wirtschaftliches leben zu ermöglichen
das soll doch nicht eine
parteipolitische frage werden warum holt
die regierung immer nur die einen
experten und warum spricht sich auch mit
den anderen experten den streiks den
schmied kann asitz dieser welt wenn der
chef der bundesvereinigung der kassen
ärzte der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung sich äußert das ist ja
kein lager der spricht für alle
niedergelassenen ärztinnen und ärzte in
deutschland das können politiker nicht
einfach so vom tisch wischen sprechen
sie zu viel mit herrn thorsten und zu
wenig mit den streger drucken nein aber
die argumentation erweckte jetzt ein
vollkommen falschen eindruck nämlich aus
richtung ein paar wenige um ein paar
wenige besonders gefährdete handeln die
man halt schützen muss wenn man sich die
situation in deutschland anschaut und
unsere gesellschaft und die über 65
jährigen die noch mal besonders
gefährdet sind diejenigen mit
vorerkrankungen die nun mal besonders
gefertigt sind wenn man die alle
zusammennimmt dann reden wir von einem
drittel der gesellschaft und bei einem
drittel der gesellschaft dass sie
besonders schützen wollen das kann man
halt nur dann tun indem alle dann auch
eine bereitschaft erklären etwas weniger
an kontakten zu haben nur dann
funktioniert der schutz in unserer
gesellschaft der besonders betroffenen
den eindruck zu erwecken man könnte das
mit 23 lieferungen vorhaus irgendwie
hinkriegen das ist schlichtweg falsch
und deswegen stehen einmal ich möchte
ihnen an ideen wir auch reden die gegner
der aktuellen politik sind die sagen am
schluss ihr müsst die kontakte
reduzieren sie sagen sie sind ein
anderer stelle jetzt zu machen und wir
sagen wenn wir schule nicht wollen kita
nicht wollen
das wirtschaftsleben nicht unter die
leitung dieser
bereich bei den punkt wären wir ja eine
meinung dass wir die kontakte reduzieren
dass man nur zu fünft beispielsweise
sich trifft nur zwei haushalte da ist ja
gar nicht der dissens
das kann ja dann durchaus weiter
fortgesetzt werden aber darüber hinaus
muss was möglich sei